[Música]
bueno en mi nombre es franklin moreno
tengo el departamento del chocó en la
ciudad
ahora estoy aquí digo bueno ya hago yo
aquí montado y después de verlo de rap y
la super chaqueta y todo dice uno que
como raro estar acá pero hoy quiero
contarles algo que sé que quizás muchos
de ustedes desconocen sí y es que yo
vengo de un departamento que tiene uno
de los índices de pobreza más alto del
país
estamos hablando de un 62,8 por ciento
pero qué es lo grande de todo esto que a
pesar de esto no perdemos nosotros los
chocoanos
[Música]
tenemos
la cuarta tasa de desempleo es alta del
país
y aquí estamos con un 11 por ciento pero
sin embargo seguimos los días
ya llevo tres horas sentado a la mitad
[Música]
mitre
tenemos el récord
y de necesidades básicas insatisfechas
básicas insatisfechas con un 79,1 por
ciento
pero aún así seguimos bailando
[Música]
si como todo puedes ver y dirán no yo ya
no viviría tienen departamentos que
tienen muchas necesidades pero
gracias a dos entidades que es la
fundación one pablo gutierrez cázares y
la empresa de publicidad müller lot nos
enseñaron algo muy importante y es que
nosotros los chocoanos tenemos algo que
el mundo necesita y en este caso es
sabor
y todo el mundo
[Música]
adicionales gracias
adicional de este sabor que tenemos a
través de nuestra ocasión podemos crear
líderes para que esta realidad el día
mañana cambio quizás esto nosotros no lo
hemos visto cierto y por eso hoy
decidimos salir adelante exportando lo
mejor que tenemos nuestra alegría
nuestro sabor y nuestro interés va más
allá de tu actitud mucha tiempo voy a
teto
de la sociedad
rico rico rico con la pierna pierna
[Música]
con las piernas
allí
aquí las
[Música]
bello
aquí una bulla la gente mente cesa
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ahí
a comentar
más
baja
como buena la rosa hoy y james blunt la
ley
oye qué está pasando aquí que todo están
bailando está pasando sabrosos se la
están gozando oye qué está pasando aquí
que todos están bailando
están pasando sabrosos se la están
gozando
la rumba está arriba y ahí está el niche
todo el mundo avanza porque hay un tema
tan sabroso porque es el meeting el
niche en un mes y el parienta bueno
porque es el del concept aprendo porque
ayudó el mundo se prende cuando hay un
el michel hay más que vacaciones estamos
full ponemos la rumba arriba y todo el
mundo está full bien a vivencia o
bastante y ya tenemos la sabrosura en la
moto mentón
sabroso bastante pegajoso mutxamel la
dieta para que los en sabrosos o
bastante pegajoso muchas velas de las
más que los seis la luz está arriba y
ahí está el todo algunos a porque hay un
tema tan sabroso por gente el niche el
big tent el mar en está bueno porque
está el del concept hablando cuando hay
un el mundial se prende cuando hay un
dicho el míster usted repite hasta que
la está montando el vice que llegó que
la pone arriba y se mantiene gozando él
dice que llegó pero aquí todo el mundo
vacilando poder leche que llegó sólo a
que el teatro le haga una bulla que el
pan para la pasta para la planta para mí
solo
dónde está la muera soltera
[Música]
hoy es ai ai ai ai dime qué fue que pasó
que los niches llegaron se quedaron
junto poniendo la rumba davis todo el
gusto y hasta el mucho que no baila
sentado se lo llegó la raza quedó y en
la raza que nos hablaba sea que disfruto
que tengamos mala hora negro sabroso
como el cb yo te duro bonobo por haberla
de la triste el dj
le mete un sabroso ha mandado el dj
simplemente sabroso
el nikkei ni le mete sabroso
el 16 y le meten sabroso y marcano
[Música]
de la noche
[Aplausos]
me sé lo que pasó con la cerveza tres
horas sentado ahí en la mesa estoy que
me tomo la mente se me estresa hoy estoy
que me dañó menos por la calle que hoy
es jueves y yo ando sábado viendo hay
que mediar con la plata del mercado by
diego cambias y quedé endeudado firmase
un traguito asiste adulterado
hasta que salga el sol
vamos son más más más más con la botella
de licor
como papas son manzanas más baja hasta
que salga el sol
vamos a tomar otra botella de vino
llevo tres días con las mismas ropas me
huele al [ __ ] en la boca el celular no
tengo sin tapar me faltó zapatos ya no
existe esto ya se ha dado porque estoy
pelao lo que me tomé base batería pues
mediante la plata del mercado y mi mujer
es que esta [ __ ] me dijo en la cara
libra desgracia de donde tuviese grandes
en el lado estaba en las fiestas
gastándome el sueldo no te acuestes
porque me devuelvo como a mis amigos
para ver quién me enfrente para pagarle
al mesero la cuenta me escupan la doña
porque está molesta y con lo que quede
como mamá
vamos a tomar más mamás otra botella de
licor y otra vez
vamos a tomar nuevas más tarde salga el
sol o más
voy a solo botón que me tomo y el daño
que causan lo asumo no embarazo entre lo
que consumo
estoy sábado cuentas vamos a ver déjame
bella suma vamos a fumar me veía bailar
bien en seguridad no hay quien te todo
vuelve a estar mal y me encanta sin
bailar me encanta como me mueve es esa
más cuando en el changa vamos tanto
pedazos y hace una prestancia y vamos a
ver me vaya no vamos a fumar
mira este curita para tocar
[Música]
[Aplausos]
tenemos
vamos a gritar
[Música]
[Aplausos]
e
no
[Música]
y allá
y
[Música]
y éste contenía
cuando es una bulla de esta enfermedad
[Aplausos]
[Música]
para ti
no
bueno
la gente no conoce una chica
allá en bogotá
ella estaba buena
se me hizo una mueca
pero había un problema bajo la forma de
la chambre tenía paralizado
qué es lo que yo quería ver
no lo vi por ningún lado ella está buena
tiene cuerpo tiene cara pero gustó para
nada na na na na na na na na na na na na
ella está buena tiene cuerpo de décadas
pero gustó para nada na na na na na na
na na si yo le dije fue con mi bote que
llegue
vivos de que quería
pero aquí miro allá y no veo dónde vivo
de que quede acá
vivos de que cage
hay vino aquí me vaya y no veo si se me
pega el agua agarra la pluma como la
rata le voy a está bien y el [ __ ] la
va a salvar mi llamada
[Aplausos]
y a pata pata pata pata pata pata
si se me pega la guarda rap como las
ratas degollada y el alba
para que llamada pata pata más abajo
ella está buena tiene el cuerpo tiene
cara pero puesto hay una nana nada bueno
le bajó enseñar cómo se baila en el
pacífico movimiento movimiento abajo
abajo
para los pagos
[Música]
y el de comer pollo huevos y pollos
[Aplausos]
el movimiento sexual es darle a la
habana
para hacer todo esto
para arriba
[Música]
1er
sólo en la palma además de la palma
palma del alma máter se repite no
comemos depuesto ya después sí
[Aplausos]
estamos enrumbados no tenemos plata la
pasamos sabroso también como dicen en
bogotá no estamos de sufrimiento estamos
de sufrimiento
no estamos el sufrimiento y palmas
palmas y palmas
galácticos personas las quitamos en
señal para usos pastas de champeta que
alguien avalancha puestas esta que
quieres no no era y todo ese tiempo que
la versión beta y limitarme a la venta
pero aquí los que ya se llama la gaceta
interpreta estos métodos
donde están los que mandan en la casa
donde están los hombres se quedaron a
practicar estos pases sencillos yo creo
que todos hemos matado a buscar a chando
6 bien entre vamos a llamar el mata
cucaracha pero con ríe
entonces para tirar la pierna derecha
adelante para mover en esta posición
como una manera de jugar hachas y logra
el centro cierto ahora vamos adicionar
los brazos nuevamente atrás unos
procesos pueden acá y otra vez acá estar
tú vamos a decirle vamos a buscar apoyo
de la pista bien
dj por el ritmo dj porque el ritmo dj
pone el ritmo display con el ritmo dj
porque el ritmo dj ponga el ritmo que va
a improvisar estamos en el tema y no
vamos a vacilar todo el mundo con las
palmas con las palmas dice para día de
alguna bulla que suele la rumba
todos
vamos con el pase
[Aplausos]
con ellos
listo caracas 12 y 12 12 12 12 12
[Música]
[Aplausos]
pero la segunda fase
muchas personas me decían yo cómo hago
para no ser tan tieso para poder el
cuerpo sencillo el cuerpo tiene un curso
y entonces cuando lo usamos bailará de
solo cuerpo como ríos para en este caso
vamos a tratar de al es un movimiento la
estructura normal
vamos a hacer un pequeño círculo excurso
el cuerpo pero vamos a hacer aquí
de sabor
y esto es el sabor
ahí está la piel
vamos
estamos ahora vamos
[Música]
el último
[Aplausos]
yo señalé un delito a ello sin música yo
quiero está sin música mohamed pues
ustedes conmigo dice así está nativo ya
pero no sé por qué
venga aquí me va a quedar el francés no
quiere bailar están activos ya vamos
conmigo para la mano aquí en la cintura
está maíz hay un poquito para abajo para
abajo para abajo
nada hay otro poco para abajo para abajo
vaya más para lavados
y yo un poquito para arriba y un poquito
a poquito cha cha cha cha cha cha
movimientos pélvicos
y yo te traigo una que es buena con el
movimiento pélvico
pero aquí
ahora ustedes le van a enseñar a ellos
primero el movimiento pélvico para que
ellos lo cojan cierto 321 movimiento
pélvico movimiento pélvico movimiento
pélvico movimiento pélvico
pélvico movimiento pélvico bueno
sencillo que vamos a hacer tiramos esta
parte adelante cierto si tiramos la
parte de abajo adelante giramos como el
pecho un poco atrás ya lo vieron cierto
entonces esta bailarina que te vamos a
marcarlo en 2 12 12 esos 12
[Música]
y
[Aplausos]
movimientos bélicos y bajando a caer en
movimiento político adelante
tiene movimiento que le vais
y para mí
quiero
[Música]
para mí yo voy a empezar antes del coro
voy a pensar con quiero ver tu
movimiento quiero ver el tuyo el tuyo el
tuyo y el tuyo y después todo para quien
vaya sus pases que quieras y después
vamos a pelvis y ritmo
les traje
desde el principio
repito cuál es el ciclo fácil
quiero ver tu movimiento movimientos
movimientos movimiento
ese movimiento movimientos
[Aplausos]
505 movimiento pélvico movimiento
pélvico
pero movimiento pélvico exóticos dijo el
siguiente movimiento
de lunáticos atento a lo que puedo
[Aplausos]
el último reto es el movimiento por el
disco listo finalizamos porque le
tomamos allá pues
no vamos a ver
bueno ya dale siegel del volumen del
volumen
a mí
yo quiero ver tu movimiento
la mamacita ahora muestra vez en
movimiento movimiento mientras tanto
vamos
[Música]
que ya está en la calle la gracia
en nombre del proyecto choco dudar del
pacífico colombiano de esquí tocho con
las piernas en nosotros la tierra del
encanto el vacile para nosotros fue un
placer estar aquí mostrando un poquito
de lo que hacemos los que vivimos
diariamente les damos las gracias a
ustedes por la oportunidad por su
valioso tiempo escucharnos y saben que
hablando se estresa no vacilamos aquí en
el defensa pero tú sabes bien que a mí
no me da tristeza y cuando estoy
animando no me da pereza así que tranca
yo no digo aleluya yo quiero que toda la
gente que se gozo es torneado una bulla
muchas gracias los invitamos a que
ingresen a la plataforma oportunidad
para que aprendan a bailar champeta como
vieron es fácil
ahora que ustedes mismos
[Aplausos]
[Música]